at this weekend fallen heroes will be
honored as the annual ride for the
fallen rolls right into town and part of
that the annual cxc heroes classic
charity hockey game at city national
arena jason griego here to talk about it
and i'm sad that john langler can't be
here because this is something that he
absolutely loves and takes part in
tell me about the event he is yeah john
john's a great guy we do enjoy having
him but uh you know unfortunately we'll
be here this weekend but we're super
excited uh once again coast to coast
comes in annually
it's a pretty special event that they do
and and the vegas veterans hockey
foundation being able to
actually support them and help them with
this is kind of near and dear as another
veteran organization
they start off in los angeles they drive
across the country and end up in
arlington cemetery on september the 8th
oh wow so as they go across the you know
the country they stop at different
places uh texas arizona
um this is the stop yes so we host the
heroes classic game at city national
arena on sunday
okay five o'clock um and anybody can go
and watch any anybody can come in if
this yep they can come in it's just they
ask for a donation to help
complete uh support their cause so
it's for the families of special forces
in the special forces community and what
they do is
it is they they help with you know um
mental health with um uh you know ptsd
yep it helps the families
um so it's near and dear to us to be
able to you know support them it's uh
it's it's not just a hockey game it's
it's a very meaningful fun hockey game
now don't get me wrong it's going to be
a fast game we have some nhl alumni this
year oh okay let's talk about that
because i know people want to see you
know kind of who's the big stars that
are going to be out there we'll have
derek england okay oh okay he's a big
gold knight yep
okay
some silver knights we'll have gage
quinney excellent we have some former
wranglers players well look at that yep
eric lampe okay uh
adam naglich so if you're a big hockey
fan you're going to recognize all these
names you're going to want to go out and
see these guys but really i mean the
ultimate goal here jason is to support
the veterans and to do it in a fun way
it is yep it'll be a very meaningful fun
fast game and yet at the same time you
can kind of uh feel good about making
sure that you're supporting a very much
needed cause so it doesn't matter which
team wins we're we're rooting for both
well we're going to go with white i'm
playing for white this year maybe not
okay cheer for history
well we appreciate you being here uh if
folks want more information one more
time tell them where it is when it is
and how they can get involved yes it's
the coast to coast heroes classic
charity hockey game okay city national
arena
this sunday five o'clock perfect jason
awesome good luck thank you good luck to
your team and to the other team too
we'll give you a little bit of love all
good thanks for having us we really
appreciate the support we appreciate you
coming on the show thank you